The CDC's Anne Schuchat and Emory's Dr. Matthew Keady
recently met with local reporters at Emory University Hospital.
They were on hand to explain how President Trump's
recent announcement on national policy concerning the opioid crisis
might flow down to hospitals like Emory.
"We're in the middle of a fast-moving, tragic epidemic.
of opioid overdoses and other complications of opioid use disorder.
The announcement today is about putting a stop to the epidemic."
The CDC has reported a 30% increase in
emergency department visits for opioid overdoses nationwide.
Emergency doctors like Keady confirm an alarming increase in cases.
"We see it on a daily basis.
People will come in with overdoses or the consequences of opioid overuse."
"What we think is going on is a lot of over-prescription
with opioids followed by a wave of the epidemic
related to heroin, and a third wave related to
illicitly manufactured fentanyl and other fentanyl-like drugs.
Over 42,000 people in the U.S. died in 2016 of opioid overdose,
more than any other year on record.
"One of the goals of this announcement is to reduce
opioid prescribing by 30 percent in three years.
A second of the goals is for all federal prescribers
to be using best practices for pain management within five years.
Experts are also looking at enhancing systems like
Georgia's prescription drug monitoring program
to better track patients' prescriptions.
"So that in any state that you're prescribing
you have access to the prescribing data from other states
and that within the state, your prescription drug monitoring
program information talks to the other systems."
For its part, Emory is on board to significantly
reduce the number of opioid prescriptions it issues.
"Using best practices and making sure that when we
talk about prescribing patterns at Emory,
we're all speaking the same language,
specifically for opioid use. I think that's the biggest impact we can make."